what's up guys it's Samuel leaves here
and massive happy Merry Christmas you
know what oh I made a commitment to do a
video every single day and even though
it's Christmas doesn't mean I'm not
gonna be putting a video out literally
even if it means I have to jump out of
the busy house on Christmas Day and sit
in my car to get some piece of words to
a video today I willing to bring
something amazing to you normally what
happens over the Christmas period
it's a strange weird period where no one
knows what day of the week it is and it
won't kind of just eats and sleeps and
doesn't know what's going on and then
suddenly before you know it boom January
comes you're back into the rat race
you're back into the normality of
everything and I want to set you up to
have the best decade you could ever
comprehend I want to set you up to the
best year to the best January so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you five
things five little things to do every
day as from tomorrow so 26th Boxing Day
27 28 29 30 earth so you've got five
little things to do over the next five
days this is my homework and I believe
me come January you're gonna be head and
shoulders above all the other property
investors out there so this is the
homework this is the plan and I hope
that you actually do this today watch
this video and then just relax okay
drink some wine relax
have some leftover Yorkshire puddings
but tomorrow on Boxing Day I want to for
you I want tomorrow to be planning day
okay 26 tomorrow Thursday planning day
what I mean by planning if you do not
have a plan then you do your plan is to
fail so you're planning to me what's the
next property gonna be that you buy if
you're just starting out what's your
first deal if you've already been in
property well what's the next property
deal
write that down get really clear on on
also why are you doing this why you want
financial freedom and what exactly is
the next property going to be and write
it down so if you've got a written goal
it's suddenly much more likely to happen
so tomorrow that's your homework 27th
what next branding day it's not about
what you know it's not just about who
you know it's also about who knows you
now I want you to tell the world what
your next property is going to be now
you can tell your aunt's your uncle's
your kids you can tell your spouse your
brothers your sisters but I would
suggest that you head down to my
Facebook group with 25
and other property investors that want
you to win in this industry and post on
the group so the group is property
investors with Samuel Leeds go on there
and post hey my name is Lauren or Dave
and my next deal is going to be and
speak it out when you speak it out
you speak it into existence and suddenly
some people will be against you but go
on the group and everyone be supporting
you and helping you and brainstorm with
you how you can make that happen
you are branding yourself you are
speaking it out into existence you are
telling the world that you are a
property investor and what your goal and
after your planning day is that's the on
the 27th the 28th Saturday what day is
that going to be well right now you've
got your plan you've spoken it out
you've branded yourself you've told the
world you've told 25 other 25,000 other
property investors 28 saturday is deal
finding day that's when I want you to go
on Rightmove Zoopla spare room open red
gum tree go on all these sites where
people have got their houses for sale
for rent and depending on what type of
strategy depending on what your next
deals going to be find loads of leads
fine viewings deal finding day you know
what in between Christmas and New Year
is such a good time instead of scrolling
on Facebook and scrolling on Instagram
scroll the houses see what investments
are available find lots of opportunities
maybe even post them on the Facebook
group and say this is what I'm thinking
people don't do that because everyone
would do it now they won't because it's
your strategy in your area with your
like everyone's got their own thing
going on so post I get people's feedback
it's deal finding day ready for the 30th
and the 30th is a Sunday and that is
learning day growing day on the 30th
which is a Sunday I want you to just
fill your mind whatever now she's just
relaxing doesn't even know what day it
is
nothing's open everything's closed the
estate agents are closed everything's
closed I want you to just really spend
time learning growing maybe read some
books visit to some podcasts and if you
haven't already that's the day that's
the day I want you to book on the
property investors crash course it's a
free program two days free program
there's different dates available in the
new year on Sunday the 30th of December
book on the property investors crash
course if you want to
in property you need first to invest in
yourself you're the best investment if
that's if that's investing money
investing time is growing day learning
day education day ready for Monday
Monday the 30th no one knows what day it
is and was like what day is it what's
going on what's happening the shops are
open it's a working day the estate
agents are open at this point you've got
your plan you branded yourself you have
found lots of deals now what you think
you're gonna do
you've also booked on the crash course
you're gonna book shed loads of property
viewings the 30th here's the challenge
and hopefully you guys will be posting
on the Facebook group I'll be able to
keep you in check keep you account on
the 30th the person who books the most
viewings wins I want you to go
absolutely crazy booking viewings and
tell you tell you what because it's
Christmas he's not going to do the
person who books the most viewings let's
say you put 30 views are some absolutely
crazy I will personally send one of my
team to go out and spend a day with you
holding your hand on the viewings that's
what I'm gonna do why because it's
Christmas because it's Christmas so
share on the Facebook group there but
you to qualify you have to share on the
Facebook group on the 27th you have to
have booked obviously lots of properties
I found lots of properties on the 28th
you need to have booked on the crash
course on the 29th which is a Sunday
then on Monday the 30th units with
booked loads of viewings put it on the
Facebook group say how many of us you've
booked and I'll send one of my
professional property investing experts
to come out with you for the whole day
one on one and go through the views that
you bought everyone else will enter
January January the 1st and they blow oh
man well I'll back to work soon what's
going on not you not you you're gonna be
on the crash course you're gonna you're
going to be educated you're going to be
branded and you're gonna have loads of
viewings and properties to see in the
new year so I'm excited those are the
things always do over the next five days
I tell you what I worked a long some of
music's exercises might take 15 minutes
don't even know it some people spend 15
minutes on the toilet just get on with
it do it I can't wait to see your
success because your success is my
oxygen even if it means getting out of
my house on Christmas Day and shooting
your video to see
so guys thank you so much for watching
and if you don't subscribe to the
channel I think you'll be a pretty good
day to subscribe to the channel it's
Christmas subscribe smash the like
button and drop back drop a message
below
just tell me Merry Christmas anything
just drop a comment below merry
Christmas from the Leeds family from the
freedom formula from all the property
investors in our team to you on this
very special day oh my goodness I almost
forgot tomorrow 7:00 p.m. guess let's go
live the financial freedom challenge in
London baby
so tune as well 7:00 p.m. tomorrow watch
the financial freedom challenge in
London me starting again from scratch
see what happens all right CJ thanks so
much I'm done now I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done over run out over now